have you ever seen goat poo yeah no I
love this stuff well I I get it blessed
I got blast I think some of the
blessings went in my pants
unless I bless myself after the blessing
I was gonna say I don't know how you're
wearing your pants for the blessings to
go in your pants thank you very much
I'm truly blessed what an honor this is
Donna our goat Grandma she's taking care
of the blessings now I'm gonna say it
makes moving a little more precarious
when it comes to the positions
now this is called downward facing sweep
I mean I've really at least I know what
I'm not into now oh I don't know you
seem pretty into it am I the toilet of
the class